the past few days have convinced me more
than ever that the Democrats and their
American media sycophants are feverishly
attempting to use the hashtag Neetu
moment for Trump's undoing
now that the Democrats have extracted
this massive increase in domestic
spending in the budget bill they've
essentially given up on the idea of
working with the Republicans to actually
improve the country and solve some
problems Pelosi Schumer Durbin have come
to the conclusion that the only way to
beat Trump is to avoid debates on his
policies which let's face it for the
most part are showing signs of working
and so what they're instead doing is
resorting to full-on demonization and
guilt by association and sadly it was
obvious almost from the start that the
me2 movement would become more about
politics than justice you think about it
justice requires more than an accusation
in a denial it involves probable cause
the rules of evidence no hearsay allowed
and the cross-examination of witnesses
for instance you know this antiquated
notion of innocent until proven guilty
now of course in some cases the evidence
is overwhelming you think about Harvey
Weinstein and Kevin Spacey they come to
mind and they're disgusting even
criminal behavior was well known by the
glitterati for decades but after the two
went off to rehab and the me2 thing
really ramped up let's face it the folks
pushing the movement really moved on to
their real target Donald J Trump if
anyone knows about inappropriate
behavior in the workplace at MDC its
Donald J Trump
[Applause]
that he's him there's one industry that
isn't even trying to get rid of sexual
predators and that is politics do you
want to be part of sexual assault month
I mean I mean when do I start
that's such a bad impersonation Trump by
the way I'm sorry it's really lame
remember it last week as well the press
exploded with stories about that guy Rob
Porter a name most of you hadn't heard
of before last week well he's a former
staff secretary to President Trump who
was accused by two former wives and a
recent girlfriend of abusive behavior
his reportedly tumultuous relationships
to say the least apparently didn't
however affect his work which by all
accounts was top-notch even one of his
ex-wives said she didn't think he should
be fired despite what she claimed were
his anger problems and on Friday the
president refused to throw Porter to the
wolves I found out about it recently and
I was surprised by it but we certainly
wish him well it's a obviously tough
time for him he did a very good job when
he was in the White House and we hope he
has a wonderful career and hopefully he
will have a great career ahead of him he
says he's innocent and I think you have
to remember that he said very strongly
yesterday that he's innocent
well that was heresy because apparently
the only acceptable response from the
president would have been condemning
Porter to a life of misery and inviting
the wives to the White House for a me to
lunch trumpism doesn't merely tolerate
sexual abuse sexual abuse is a very apt
metaphor for everything trumpism is this
is a rape culture presidency and Donald
Trump has become the commander in chief
of American rape culture this is a
sexist racist and misogynistic
administration and government from ism
is not about anything else more than
misogyny he continues to not be for not
to speak up for the
victims or the people have been abused
before their abusers well it's fine I
think the president could have mentioned
the people who claimed that Porter did
that to him absolutely the ex-wife sure
could have mentioned it maybe probably
should have but excuse me if I don't
think that the Democrats really care all
that much about women who are victims of
abuse and harassment remember folks they
came pained with Bill Clinton they
partied with Harvey they ridiculed Paula
Jones and Juanita Broderick and they
look the other way when abuse was
occurring for years because it helped
them professionally personally
politically or all three it was only
when Rose McGowan and Ronan Farrow
exposed the truth about Weinstein that
stars starlets producers directors and
even Hillary Clinton were forced to
issue their late in the game
denunciations and ditto for Congress you
know they didn't begin their
soul-searching moments until reports
emerged of a secret House slush fund
that was used to pay settlements to
those who were accused of wrongdoing
politicians and staff oh and by the way
while we're on that congressman john
conyers who was forced into retirement
over harassment allegations he was an
old Lech for years and everybody knew
that so I asked you if these Democrats
cared so much about women especially
vulnerable young women why didn't any of
them speak up oh we all know why now
this this is really good even a Supreme
Court justice seems to be hopping on the
me2 bandwagon
citing a toxic testosterone-filled
atmosphere for Hillary's election loss I
think it was difficult for Hillary
Clinton to get by even if the macho
atmosphere prevailing during that
campaign anyone who watched watched that
campaign unfold would answer that the
same way I did
yes sexism was played a prominent part
I'm sure she can decide any case
involving Trump without any prejudice
whatsoever it's an outrage
this is another reason by the way to
question life tenure for Supreme Court
justices she has basically become a
political pundit look out Rachel Maddow
she could have her own show and I'm a
simpie see and then there was 20 20
Democrat hopeful New York senator
Kirsten Gillibrand I think he should
resign and if he's unwilling to do that
which is what I assume then Congress
should hold him accountable we are
obligated to have hearings and has she
ever returned that money the bill
clinton raised for her I haven't
followed that but I doubt it look
Gillibrand has fully weaponized and I'm
sick of that word but I'm gonna use it
anyway fully weaponized the me to hash
tag movement with the intention of
driving the female vote in the midterms
and ultimately sweeping herself right
into the Oval Office and while we all
condemn actual abuse and harassment in
all of its forms what regardless of
whether it where it occurs the last time
I checked jobs the economy health care
education were still the top issues for
voters including women nonetheless let's
face it a shift may be underway
especially among younger voters Ted Cruz
said over the weekend that the left
would crawl over broken glass to vote in
the midterms thinking about it he's
probably right and if Gillibrand has her
way most of those with cuts on their
hands and knees are going to be women
the left is really busy marshalling
their allies their resources across the
cultural and political spectrum to make
the president toxic to women it
ultimately Drive him from office and the
president has already seen some erosion
and his female support Democrats know
this is a magic bullet for them if they
turn the women's vote by just a few
percentage points it can mean the
difference in the midterms and in 2020
but I want to be clear this is
by all means not a lost cause that's not
what I'm saying contrary to what MSNBC
CNN would have you believe most women
want greater economic opportunities they
want safe streets they want solid public
schools for their kids and they want
health care that covers the big stuff
like that's for most of us and the
president is doing more on all of those
fronts then I think the past two
presidents combined and he needs to sell
this directly to the voters including
women voters directly but tone matters
especially with women it's not just what
you say but how you say it and sometimes
it's also what you fail to say that can
be just as important as what you do say
so if he comes on too strong or too
defensively and tweets or an
off-the-cuff exchanges with reporters
he could set himself back and he could
confirm the unfair caricature the left
promotes 24/7 and that could mean
disastrous results and that's the angle